This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste.
本集由 Hive 赞助。英国曾凭藉工业力量的强大革新了未来。但现在，你可以借助 Hive 的力量改变你自己的能源未来并掌控主动权。Hive 充分利用了太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电能，并使你能够将多余的电量回售给电网。而且，Hive 的温控器让你只需动动大拇指和赞叹的眉头，就能为家里供暖。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其保持在你精确想要的温度。没有烟雾，没有浪费。
Hive's EV charger lets your car charge quietly overnight. Recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together. Heating, charging and solar. managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology.
Hive 的电动汽车充电器让你的汽车在夜间静音充电。在你休息的同时为你补充电量。Hive 将这一切完美融合。供暖、充电和太阳能，全部通过一个简单的应用程序进行管理，开启一场静谧的革命。在漫长的电力发展史中，Hive 助你最终认清自己的能量。前往 hivehome.com 了解更多详情，须视实地勘测和适用情况而定。Hive 应用程序兼容特定的技术。
Paid for surplus requires SEG tariff. Hi, everybody. Welcome to the rest is history and happy new year. And welcome back to the recording of the live show that Tom and I did at the Royal Albert Hall in London on the 4th of May 2025. Now, on Monday, you should have heard the first half of that show, which was the episode on the Russian composer, Chikovsky. And in today's episode, we'll be the first half of that show, which was the episode on the Russian composer, Chikovsky. And in today's episode, we'll will be broadcasting the second half of that show. And this is in one of the most influential incendiary and controversial composers, indeed artists of any kind in world history. And the name of that man is Richard Wagner. And so on the I'm going to be the I'm going to be able to
出售剩余电力需要开通 SEG 补贴费率。大家好。欢迎来到《历史其余部分》（The Rest is History），新年快乐。欢迎回来收听我和汤姆于 2025 年 5 月 4 日在伦敦皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅举办的现场演出的录音。那么，在周一，你们应该已经听过那场演出前半部分的内容，也就是关于俄罗斯作曲家柴可夫斯基的那集。而在今天的节目中，我们将播出那场演出的前半部分，也就是关于俄罗斯作曲家柴可夫斯基的那集。而在今天的节目中，我们将播出那场演出的后半部分。这是一位在世界历史上最具影响力、最具煽动力和最具争议的作曲家，甚至可以说是任何类型的艺术家。这个人的名字就是理查德·瓦格纳。所以在这个...
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to my and my and I'm going I'm going I'm going
我将要... 我将要... 我将要... 我的... 我的... 我将要... 我将要... 我将要...
and I'm We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. We're going to be And so on the I'm going to be the I'm going to
而我将... 我们将要能够... 我将要... 我将要... 我们将要... 所以在这个... 我将要成为... 我将要...
I'm going to I'm going to and the I'm going to I'm Hell and hope, High and hope, the hall,
我将要... 我将要... 和这个... 我将要... 地狱与希望，高处与希望，大厅，
the hall, the heart, Heming it, Hey, hey, I'm interested in this. I'll draw, Oh, and God, I'll do, I'll do it, I'll do it, oh, oh my God, and I'm. I'm here. I'm here.
大厅，心脏，编织它，嘿，嘿，我对这个很感兴趣。我会画画，哦，天哪，我会做，我会做，我会做，哦，天哪，还有我。我在这里。我在这里。
I'm here. Villeh! Ville! Ville! The vall! The vosson! The russon! Hear the berns, fell from an an anewan,
我在这里。维勒！维尔！维尔！瓦尔！沃森！鲁森！听听那些饱经风霜的人，从一个新地方落下，
how's our helen has, it's good enough. The her head in fact that you're a her head in creme, is the grueless, you're still the gruebe. Oh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, and you, Oh, I don't know, you're so long. More night cups! You see what I'm here?
我们的海伦怎么样，这已经够好了。她的脑子实际上，你是个... 她的脑子在奶油里，真是太残酷了，你仍然是那个粗鲁的人。哦，哈哈哈哈哈哈哈，还有你，哦，我不知道，你待了这么久。再来杯睡前酒！你看到我在这里干什么了吗？
I'm here another chundah? I'm a true. I'm here. I'm here. I am proud. Oh, no. Oh, no. I'm a man.
我在这里还有另一个傻瓜吗？我是一个真实的人。我在这里。我在这里。我感到骄傲。哦，不。哦，不。我是一个男人。
I'm here you, you know, and I'm still, I'm still, I. In the world, in the world, in the wretched, Oh, I'm sorry to see him.
我在这里，你知道，我仍然，我仍然，我。在这个世界上，在这个世界上，在悲惨的世界里，哦，我很遗憾看到他。
Oh, you're proud! Oh, you're proud! I love! Oh, oh you're true! I love! I love! I love! I love!
哦，你很骄傲！哦，你很骄傲！我爱！哦，哦，你是真的！我爱！我爱！我爱！我爱！
I'm not true! I love! I love! I love! I love! I love! I love! Oh, my God!
我不是真的！我爱！我爱！我爱！我爱！我爱！我爱！哦，天哪！
Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh! Oh! Oh! Ladies and Ladies and gentlemen, Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome back to the stage, the host of the rest is history,
哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦！哦！哦！女士们，女士们，先生们，女士们，先生们，请欢迎再次回到舞台，
Tom Holland and Dominic Sambro. Thank you. Thank you very much. Welcome back, everybody. Tom, amazing to see that some people are still here. Few. So, that was, as many of you will know, the ride of the Valkyries, from the Opera de Valkura,
《历史其余部分》的主持人，汤姆·霍兰和多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。谢谢。非常感谢。欢迎大家回来。汤姆，很高兴看到有些人还在。呼。那么，正如你们许多人所知，那是来自歌剧《女武神》中的《女武神的骑行》，
the Valkyrie, the Divine Shield Maiden, And our divine shield maidens tonight were Christine Burris, Mari Wynne Williams, Ella de Jong, Rebecca Afonwi-Jones, Katie Stevenson, and Marta Fontenelle's Simmons. And weren't they spectacular? And Dominic, we ended part one with a banger and we've begun part two with another absolute banger. one of the most instantly recognisable pieces of music ever written. Exactly. So if any of you are planning to stray for Vietnamese village from a helicopter, this is the ideal accompaniment, as you will know if you've seen the film, Apocalypse Now. It is, of course, emblematic of the man who wrote it,
女武神，神圣的盾牌少女，我们今晚神圣的盾牌少女是克里斯蒂娜·伯里斯、玛丽·温·威廉姆斯、艾拉·德容、丽贝卡·阿福维-琼斯、凯蒂·史蒂文森和玛塔·丰特内尔·西蒙斯。她们难道不 spectacular（壮观）吗？多米尼克，我们在第一部分以一首劲爆的曲子结尾，而在第二部分，我们又以另一首绝对劲爆的曲子开场。这是有史以来辨识度最高的音乐作品之一。确实如此。所以，如果你们有谁打算乘直升机去袭击越南村庄，这将是理想的伴奏，正如看过电影《现代启示录》的人所知道的那样。这当然是创作它的那个男人的象征，
the composer who is the subject of our second half, and that is Richard Wagner. And Tom, in the first half, we talked about how Chikovsky was described by his governess as being as brittle as porcelain, and that is not a description that anyone has ever applied to Richard Wagner. No, no, not at all, because Wagner, in all honesty, was a bit of a bruiser. This is a man who essentially bent the whole of the 19th century to his own purposes. And in fact, I would go so far as to say that he is the single most... controversial composer in the entire history of music. Would you agree with that?
也就是我们下半场的主角作曲家，理查德·瓦格纳。汤姆，在上半场，我们谈到了柴可夫斯基如何被他的家庭女教师形容为像瓷器一样易碎，而这个形容词是绝对没有人会用在理查德·瓦格纳身上的。不，不，一点也不，因为瓦格纳老实说是个有点粗暴强悍的人。这个人基本上按照自己的意愿塑造了整个 19世纪。事实上，我要说得更远一点，他可以说是整个音乐史上最具... 争议的作曲家。你同意吗？
I would absolutely agree. I mean, remember that this is a man who wrote savagely anti-Semitic essays, who was Adolf Hitler's favorite composer, and whose operas to this day have never been staged in the state of Israel. Yeah, and so it's not really surprising that there's a slight whiff of sulfur about Wagner's public reputation. I think the word we use, Tom, is pungent. Yes, as you said, pungent.
我完全同意。我的意思是，请记住，这个人写过极其反犹太主义的文章，他是阿道夫·希特勒最喜欢的作曲家，而且他的歌剧直到今天也从未在以色列国上演过。是的，所以瓦格纳的公众声誉带有一丝硫磺味也就不足为奇了。汤姆，我想我们用的词是“辛辣”。是的，正如你所说，辛辣。
And so I think the question is, does his anti-Semitism, which is absolutely gross and palpable, it is absolutely out there, does it taint his music? Are his operas, in some sense, a prefiguring of Nazism? And this is an argument that has been raging among Wagner scholars since really the late 60s, and it's obviously a very important, a very heated debate, and we will be coming to it in due course.
所以我想问题是，他的反犹太主义——这是绝对粗俗且显而易见的，是完全摆在明面上的——是否玷污了他的音乐？他的歌剧在某种程度上是否是对纳粹主义的预示？自 60 年代末以来，瓦格纳学者们一直在争论这个问题，这显然是一个非常重要、非常激烈的辩论，我们将在适的时候讨论它。
but it's absolutely not the only reason why Wagner matters and why he is a completely worthy theme for a history podcast, let alone a music podcast. And I think the reason why Wagner casts such a kind of outsized shadow over the 20th century is because he's such a massive, massive influence on the 19th century. And in fact, I think it's hard to think of of any composer, perhaps any creative artist
但这绝对不是瓦格纳重要的唯一原因，也不是他完全配得上成为历史播客（更不用说音乐播客）主题的唯一原因。我认为瓦格纳之所以在 20 世纪投下如此巨大的阴影，是因为他对 19 世纪产生了极其巨大的影响。事实上，我认为很难想到任何作曲家，甚至任何创意艺术家，
whose influence on the 19th century, the cultural influence, was more titanic than Wagner's. Right, I agree. So some of you may have come a year ago when we did Mozart and Beethoven. Now, Beethoven was Wagner's favourite composer, wasn't he? It's a great hero. And Beethoven had started a process
他对 19 世纪的文化影响比瓦格纳更具震撼力。没错，我同意。所以你们当中有些人可能一年前来听过莫扎特和贝多芬的讲座。现在，贝多芬是瓦格纳最喜欢的作曲家，对吧？这是一个伟大的英雄。贝多芬开启了一个进程，
that Wagner carried to its extreme, which is to take music out of the court, out of the palace, and to take it to the public, to take it into the heart of public life. where it still is to this day. So here we are in the royal Albert Hall. But this is not a palace.
而瓦格纳将其推向了极致，那就是将音乐带出宫廷，带出宫殿，将其带给公众，带入公共生活的心脏。音乐至今仍留在那里。所以我们现在身处皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅。但这并不是一座宫殿。
This is a kind of public theatre. And Wagner is really the midwife of institutions like this. Partly because he was such a genius, partly because his music was so influential. But also, and I think just as significantly, because Wagner never for a moment doubts that he is a genius. Dominic, I mean, we have experience of colossal egotism, don't we? We do, from our producers.
这是一种公共剧院。而瓦格纳确实是此类机构的助产士。部分原因在于他是如此天才，部分原因在于他的音乐极具影响力。但同样，而且我认为同样重要的是，瓦格纳从未有一刻怀疑自己是个天才。多米尼克，我的意思是，我们见识过极度的自负，对吧？我们确实见识过，从我们的制作人身上。
But Wagner's egotism is off the scale. But the thing is that not only, I mean, unlike us, not only is Wagner's egotism justified, but it enables him to bulldoze his way through obstructions that would absolutely have halted a less self-confident and less assertive composer. So that by the end of his life, it's not Wagner who is paying court to royalty, but the other way around. It is kings and emperors who are paying court to Wagner.
但瓦格纳的自负简直突破天际。但问题是，不仅——我的意思是，与我们不同的是——瓦格纳的自负是正当的，而且它还使他能够用推土机一般的方式扫除那些本会彻底阻碍一个自信不足、不够强势的作曲家的障碍。因此，到了他生命的尽头，不再是瓦格纳去向皇室献殷勤，而是反过来了。是国王和皇帝们在向瓦格纳献殷勤。
Yeah, and Tom, I think there's also another reason why Wagner is such an extraordinary subject for an event like this. If you compare him with Tchaikovsky, or indeed with Mozart and Beethoven, or with Johann Sebastian Bach, or most composers that you choose to mention, there are all sorts of flamboyant biographical details in Wagner. life that have no equivalent in the lives of other composers. And often kind of unexpected details. So to look at one of them, Wagner, compared to every other composer who is kind of his equal, is an unbelievably late developer.
是的，汤姆，我认为还有另一个原因，为什么瓦格纳是这样一场活动的非凡主题。如果你把他和柴可夫斯基进行比较，或者确实与莫扎特和贝多芬，或者与约翰·塞巴斯蒂安·巴赫，或者你选择提及的大多数作曲家进行比较，瓦格纳的生活中有各种各样浮华的生平细节，这是其他作曲家生平中所没有的。而且通常是某种意想不到的细节。所以看其中一个细节，与所有处于同等地位的其他作曲家相比，瓦格纳是一个难以置信的大器晚成者。
So he's born in Leipzig in Saxony in 1813. So what's that, about 25, 30 years before Chikovsky? Yep. And it's just a few months after Napoleon has begun his retreat from Moscow. so the Napoleonic wars are raging all around Wagner when he's born and baby Richard which is very hard to think of Wagner
所以他于 1813 年出生在萨克森的莱比锡。那么那是多久，比柴可夫斯基早大约 25、30 年？对。那正值拿破仑开始从莫斯科撤退几个月后，所以当瓦格纳出生时，拿破仑战争正在他身边肆虐，而小理查德——很难想象瓦格纳是
as baby Richard but he was at one point he is the last of nine children fathered by a man who then promptly dies in a very Wagnerian fashion and his mother then marries again and Wagner later in life seems to have wondered whether his stepfather had actually been his father
小理查德，但他在某个时期是九个孩子中的老幺，他的父亲随后很快以一种非常瓦格纳式的方式去世了，然后他的母亲再次结婚，瓦格纳在后来的生活中似乎怀疑过他的继父是否实际上就是他的亲生父亲。
and as we will see this theme of people with kind of uncertain paternity is a theme that runs throughout Wagner's operas. And something really important about this stepfather, though, Tom. So his stepfather was not a musical man, but he was a man of the theatre, and that was to really shape Richard Wagner's life. Yes, and lots of Wagner's elder brothers
正如我们将看到的，这种父亲身份不明的人的主题贯穿了瓦格纳的整个歌剧。不过，汤姆，关于这个继父，有一件非常重要的事情。所以他的继父不是一个懂音乐的人，但他是一个戏剧界的人，这真正塑造了理查德·瓦格纳的一生。是的，瓦格纳的很多哥哥
were also very involved in the theatre. And I think because of this kind of familial influence, Wagner grows up as a boy and then a young man who is at least as obsessed by the theatre as he is by music. I mean, he's very proficient at music, he's very interested in it, but he's not an absolute maestro in the way that Mozart is from the kind of, well, the age of three months or whatever. And so you may wonder, this being so,
也极度投入于戏剧。我想正是因为这种家庭影响，瓦格纳在成长为男孩然后是年轻人时，对戏剧的痴迷程度至少不亚于对音乐的痴迷。我的意思是，他精通音乐，他对音乐很感兴趣，但他绝对不是那种像莫扎特那样从大约三个月大或其他什么年龄就开始的绝对大师。所以你可能会想，既然如此，
why does Wagner aspire to become a composer? And I think the answer essentially is because he wants to set plays to music. Right, and that's why Wagner is drawn to opera above all, isn't it? because when we think of Vargan, we don't think of any other musical form really, but his operas. Yeah, I mean, that's essentially pretty much exclusively what he writes.
为什么瓦格纳渴望成为一名作曲家？我想答案本质上是因为他想把戏剧配上音乐。没错，这就是为什么瓦格纳最青睐歌剧，不是吗？因为当我们想到瓦格纳时，我们真的不会想到任何其他音乐形式，除了他的歌剧。是的，我的意思是，本质上他几乎只创作这个。
And his interest in opera is not just as a composer. He wants to write the librettoes, he wants to design the theatre, he essentially wants to control every last detail of the production. But I guess the problem for somebody like that is gargantuan ambitions, but does he have gargantuan means and opportunities? Well, in his teens, in his 20s,
他对歌剧的兴趣不仅限于作为一个作曲家。他想写剧本，他想设计剧院，他本质上想控制制作的每一个微小细节。但我想对于这样的人来说，问题在于他有庞大的野心，但他是否有庞大的资金和机会呢？好吧，在他十几岁、二十几岁，
and then going into his 30s, he absolutely doesn't because he's from a very humble background, relatively speaking. And all the powers of patronage in Germany at this point are still lie overwhelmingly with courts. And Germany is a kind of patchwork of kingdoms and princestoms and archbishoprics and so on. And these are the people who are really effectively the only employers that a musician can look to. And so this is the course, the slightly humiliating course
然后进入三十岁时，他绝对没有，因为相对而言，他出身非常卑微。而当时德国所有的赞助权力仍然绝大多数掌握在宫廷手中。当时的德国是一块由王国、诸侯国、大主教区等拼凑而成的拼图。这些人才是音乐家实际上唯一可以指望的雇主。所以这就是那条道路，一条从瓦格纳自己的角度来看
from Wagner's own perspective that he has to follow. as a young man. And so if we look at him in, let's take a year at random, 1848, when Wagner is 35, he's kind of done okay by the standards of most musicians. He's head of music at the Royal Court of Saxony in Dresden. But Wagner is pretty miserable. And he's miserable because he feels
作为年轻人不得不遵循的略带屈辱的道路。因此，如果我们看看他，比如说随便挑一个年份，1848年，当时瓦格纳 35 岁，按照大多数音乐家的标准，他过得还算可以。他是德累斯顿萨克森王家宫廷的音乐总监。但瓦格纳非常痛苦。他痛苦是因为他觉得
that his status as court musician is a humiliating one. On special musical occasions, he has to wear a blue coat with a kind of harp on the collar. And to Wagner, this is like the livery of a servant. He despises the local theatre. He thinks it's absolutely hopeless. He wants to pull it down and build a new one. And he hates the musical tastes of his employer
他作为宫廷音乐家的地位是一种屈辱。在特殊的音乐场合，他必须穿着一件领子上绣有某种竖琴图案的蓝色制服外套。对瓦格纳来说，这就像是仆人的制服。他鄙视当地的剧院。他认为那里简直无可救药。他想把它推倒重建一个新的。而且他讨厌他的雇主
and of the locals because they are essentially interested in operettas. And this is not where Wagner is at all. Because what Wagner wants to do is right, titanic. Titanic operas about mythology, about men of destiny, about revolution. Well, you mentioned revolution, Tom, and you claimed you've chosen a year at random, and I think that was a lie. You were correct.
以及当地人的音乐品味，因为他们基本上只对轻歌剧感兴趣。而这根本不是瓦格纳的志趣所在。因为瓦格纳想做的是创作宏大的、关于神话、关于命运之人、关于革命的宏大歌剧。好吧，你提到了革命，汤姆，你声称你随便挑了一个年份，我认为那是个谎言。你猜对了。
So 1848, as some of you will know, is the year of revolution in Europe. And by May 1849, Tom, incredible scenes, the storm clouds of revolution are gathering above Dresden and Saxon. and putting Wagner in their shadow. They absolutely are, Dominic, and Wagner couldn't be happier about this. And it may surprise people who think of Wagner as being, well, you know, let's face it, right-wing. Because actually, that's unfair.
所以正如你们中的一些人所知，1848 年是欧洲的革命之年。到了 1849 年 5 月，汤姆，不可思议的场景，革命的暴风雨密云正在德累斯顿和萨克森上空聚集，并将瓦格纳笼罩在它们的阴影之下。它们绝对是这样，多米尼克，而瓦格纳对此感到再高兴不过了。这可能会让那些认为瓦格纳是——好吧，让我们面对现实吧，右翼——的人感到惊讶。因为实际上，那是不公平的。
He has certain white-wing opinions, can't deny that. But in his essentials, he's a bit of an anarchist. In fact, I would go so far as to say a bit of a hippie, and we'll hopefully be justifying this in due course. in due course. And certainly when the threat of revolution comes to the court, he's very, very excited about it.
他确实有某些右翼观点，无可否认。但在他的本质上，他有点像个无政府主义者。事实上，我要说得更远一点，他有点像个嬉皮士，我们希望在适的时候对此进行辩解。在适的时候。而且当革命的威胁降临到宫廷时，他感到非常非常兴奋。
And that may, as the revolutionary fervor spreads across Saxony, it absolutely catches Wagner up. And so he starts publishing inflammatory pamphlets, to which he puts his own name. He starts distributing flyers around the barricades. And at one point, he shins his way up the tallest spire in Dresden to serve
随着革命激情在萨克森蔓延，它绝对将瓦格纳卷了进去。于是他开始发表煽动性的小册子，并在上面署上自己的名字。他开始在路障周围散发传单。有一次，他顺着德累斯顿最高尖顶爬上去担任
a lookout, looking for the forces of reaction who are trying to snuff out the brave revolutionaries. Right, and this is a problem if you're working for the person who's running Saxony, right? Because as everybody knows, the revolutions of 1848 and 1849 get crushed. So Wagner has effectively been backing a losing horse. He's been backing a losing horse, and the winning horse is his ex-employer who he's been insulting in pamphlets and flyers. So he's clearly guilty. of treason and the penalty for treason in Saxony is death. So Wagner is in terrible peril.
瞭望员，寻找那些试图扑灭勇敢革命者的反动派军队。没错，如果你为统治萨克森的人工作，这就是个麻烦，对吧？因为众所周知，1848 年和 1849 年的革命被镇压了。所以瓦格纳实际上是在押注一匹输掉的马。他押注了一匹输掉的马，而赢家是他的前雇主，他一直在小册子和传单中侮辱这个人。所以他显然犯了叛国罪，而萨克森叛国罪的惩罚是死刑。所以瓦格纳处境极其危险。
He has to flee for his life and he only just gets away from Saxony. And adding to the kind of the disaster state that he finds himself in is the fact that he can't, there's no obvious place of sanctuary in the rest of Germany because everywhere in Germany has experienced these revolutions. And now that they've been crushed, nobody wants to have anything to do with this failed revolutionary that Wagner has now become. And so essentially, across Germany, he has made himself persona non grata. So he ends up in Switzerland, which was some absolutely unfathomable reason he finds really boring. And I guess, you know, beggars can't be choos. What can you say? Well, Dominic, I mean, you say beggars, and that is literally what Wagner is,
他为了保命而逃亡，而且他险险逃出了萨克森。雪上加霜的是他发现自己处于一种灾难性的状态，那就是在德国的其他地方没有明显的避难所，因为德国各地都经历过这些革命。现在它们已经被镇压了，没有人想和瓦格纳现在变成的这个失败的革命者有任何瓜葛。因此，基本上，他在整个德国都成了不受欢迎的人。所以他最终来到了瑞士，出于某种绝对无法揣摩的原因，他觉得那里非常无聊。我想，你知道，叫花子没资格挑三拣四。你能说什么呢？好吧，多米尼克，我的意思是，你说叫花子，那确实就是瓦格纳的写照，
because it's not just that he's skinned. He's massively in debt. He's a man who all his life loves splashing the cash. So he has no money, he has no patron, he has no theatre where he can put his operas on, and the next five years he writes almost no music at all. And again, this is something that is unusual about Wagner when you think of the great composers.
因为不仅是他身无分文。他负债累累。他是一个一生都喜欢挥霍金钱的人。所以他没有钱，没有赞助人，没有可以上演歌剧的剧院，在接下来的五年里，他几乎没有写任何音乐。再次，当你想到伟大作曲家时，这是瓦格纳异乎寻常的一个特点。
It's hard to think of another composer of Wagner's. of Wagner's stature who for five years in the middle of his life just stops writing music. And you might think he's doing this because he's a bit depressed, he's a bit down, he's lost his self-confident, not a bit of it. Wagner has lost nothing of his self-confidence. And the five years following his escape from Dresden are absolutely not wasted, even though he isn't writing music. Because what he's doing instead, he is reading, he is writing, he is dreaming. And the fruit of these dreams will be the single most astonishing cultural achievement of the whole of the 19th century. And it will tell the story of a ring, of gods, of valkyries, of heroes.
很难想到瓦格纳这样地位的另一位作曲家，在他人生的中期有五年时间只是停止了音乐创作。你可能会认为他这样做是因为他有点沮丧，有点失落，失去了自信——一点也不是。瓦格纳一点也没有失去自信。他从德累斯顿逃亡后的五年绝对没有被浪费，尽管他没有写音乐。因为他在此期间所做的是，他在阅读，他在写作，他在做梦。而这些梦想的果实将是整个 19 世纪最令人震惊的文化成就。它将讲述一个关于戒指、关于神明、关于女武神、关于英雄的故事。
And I think it's time now for some music. And so let's hear one of these heroes. He is called Siegfried. He has been raised by Mima, a dwarf as the dwarf's own son. So there's the kind of the theme of confused patrimony. But in truth, Siegfried is the son of a dead hero whose sword, No-Tung, had been shattered to pieces by Wotan, the king of the gods. And Siegfried, he comes into Mima's forge and he finds the fragments of No-Tung
我想现在是时候听点音乐了。让我们来听听其中一位英雄。他叫齐格弗里德。他被侏儒密米抚养长大，作为侏儒自己的儿子。所以这里有一种身份混乱的血统主题。但事实上，齐格弗里德是一个死去的英雄的儿子，那英雄的宝剑“诺图ung”（Nothung）被众神之王沃坦砸成了碎片。齐格弗里德来到密米的铁匠铺，发现了“诺图ung”的碎片，
and he picks them up and he marvels at them. And do you know what he says? He says, no tongue no tongue night liquor's that is what he says oh
他把它们捡起来并啧啧称奇。你知道他说什么吗？他说，诺图ung，诺图ung，夜里的酒——他就是这么说的，哦
Tom don't that is it's applause born out of pity and embarrassment I don't think so because that is exactly what Siegfried says he then cracks up the bellows he then gets in some Viking laughter
汤姆，别这样——那是出于怜悯和尴尬的掌声。我不这么认为，因为齐格弗里德就是这么说的。他随后拉响了风箱，发出了一些维京式的狂笑，
and as the bellows are rearing as he sets to forging no-tung Mima is watching on all kind of scheming and trixie and out comes the hammer and a sword that was broken and had long seemed beyond repair starts to be repaired Right well to banish the memory of what just happened
随着风箱呼呼作响，当他着手锻造“诺图ung”时，密米在一旁阴险狡诈地看着，锤子落下来，一把断裂且长期看起来无法修复的剑开始被修复。好吧，为了驱散刚刚发生的事情的记忆，
let us hear the exultant singing of Sieg in which we hear, I think, the resolve and the implacability. And if you're a big Wagnerian, I suppose, the heroism of Richard Wagner himself. So please welcome Toby Spence and John Finden as Mima and Siegfried for the forging of No-Tung. Siegfried's forging song. Oh, ho! Oh, hey! Oh, hey!
让我们聆听西格凯旋的歌声，从中我们能听到决心和不可动摇的意志。如果你是一个坚定的瓦格纳迷，我想，还有理查德·瓦格纳本人的英雄主义。所以请欢迎托比·斯宾塞（Toby Spence）和约翰·芬登（John Finden）饰演密米和齐格弗里德，为我们带来“诺图ung的锻造”。齐格弗里德的锻造之歌。哦，哦！哦，嘿！哦，嘿！
My hammer, your haute my hammer, your haute's sword. Oh, ho! Ho! Ho! Oh, ho! Ha, ho!
我的锤子，你的高处，我的锤子，你的高处的剑。哦，哦！哦！哦！哦，哦！哈，哦！
Once fared blood, Your falves' blue, His rote's rhesen, Rutted Dixen, Ruttedtie. Cold, larktest you there, The farmer, lends you cool. Oh, oh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ya, ha! Now, has the glute's
曾经流淌过鲜血，你的折叠的蓝色，他的路线雷森，鲁特迪克森，鲁特蒂。冷，你在那里劳作，农夫，借给你凉爽。哦，哦，哈哈哈哈，呀，哈！现在，有了发光的
grunt gilded, my white hereto, the hammer-weigh, So, you spreece, to me fulke, that I'm not spruce, Go ahead. Hey-ho! Hey-ho! Ha-yo!
金块，我白色的此地，锤子的重量，所以，你向我倾诉，我并不精神，来吧。嘿-哦！嘿-哦！哈-约！
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha! Oh-ha-ha-ha-ha! Oh-ha-hae! See me to wharf, the faugh-the-the-their-fell, the fawner fell. Geree must me the lest, Laughan must me lewd
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈！哦哈哈哈哈！哦哈哈海！看我向码头，那个跌倒的，农夫倒下了。格雷必须是最后的，大笑必须是淫荡的
Oh, ho! Oh, ho! Oh, ho! Oh, oh, oh, aye! Oh, ho! Oh, hey! Oh, oh, oh, hey! The frown funk,
哦，哦！哦，哦！哦，哦！哦，哦，哦，哎！哦，哦！哦，嘿！哦，哦，哦，嘿！紧皱的放克，
How I'm I'm I'm! It's here the cuness'ness'rown's craft. Lusting, lark'st'n't you an, stelt'st'rantly and grame. Oh, ha, ha, ha, y'a, ha, y'a, ha. Then, good and hammers, it legged it me,
我是怎么怎么怎么！这里是精明者的工艺。渴望，你在那里劳作，隐秘而残酷。哦，哈哈，呀，哈，呀，哈。然后，好的和锤子，它跟随我，
With sark and stren stren stren, strick, t'n, Now, swing, the rote chamele-a-and-a-haught, and as you can't, Hallahawk! Oh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. In the brother, shoof, in the dimmere, slinging the clasp, that Heller God's
带着力量，用力，用力，挥舞，现在，挥动，旋转的变色龙和傲慢，正如你不能，哈拉霍克！哦，哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈。在兄弟中，鞋子，在昏暗中，挥舞着搭扣，那地狱之神的
Herrowne has, I've he won I can't belewain I'm fainte I'm sorry I've seen, I've seen I, I'm now, I'm down nearer,
赫罗恩有，我已经赢了，我不能相信，我快晕倒了，我很抱歉，我看到了，我看到了，我，我现在，我更近了，
the hoarse, I'm unbelled all beaft. The veracted Svark, how will he erred erred. To the Hordean, dering, God and hilt.
嘶哑的声音，我未解除武装的所有野兽。被夺走的斯瓦克，他将如何犯错。去往霍尔丹，勇敢，神与山。
From my wicker, neighed the felds, from my fern, thicket him here. God! God! Weigh, how it's fit, now after you havetest you, you're in hathes.
从我的柳条，邻近的田野，从我的蕨类灌木丛中。神！神！称量，它是如何适合的，现在在你拥有它之后，你在仇恨中。
I'm haught, I'm hushed, neither never, He said. You're two, I'm I'm trying to guance, One slag, so nunt I'm
我很高傲，我很安静，从不，他说。你们两个，我，我试着去瞥一眼，一击，所以现在我
Dershacken In chaffin' He made Chast In styrne, Father, Cestranged Stal,
德沙肯，在玩笑中，他使纯洁在严厉中，父亲，疏远的斯塔尔，
A-lebent Son, Susine Huy, Lacht In his heller Soy His faints! Heine shone!
一个活着的儿子，苏西恩·许伊，在他的地狱大豆中大笑，他的虚弱！海因闪耀！
Mimels ye gulner! Mimmy is hulning! Huln! Hurt! Hurt! Hurt! Hurt! Haldrych is witt!
密米的傻瓜！密米在咆哮！咆哮！受够了！受够了！受够了！受够了！哈尔德里奇是机智的！
To live! To live, waked I was, the vigor, Toul, lax, there, Hey, men, God!
去活！去活，我被唤醒了，活力，托尔，拉克斯，那里，嘿，男人，上帝！
Now, you lewdess, you trottsy and he. Hey, Mime, how flukes you the heart? Sondon's sicken, and a sign. We had you, that was, they were. Sane him thrushen, wend you'd the spell.
现在，你这个淫荡的家伙，你这个顽皮的家伙。嘿，密米，你的心跳得怎么样？桑顿生病了，还有一个标志。我们有了你，那是，他们是的。像个傻瓜一样捶打他，你去念咒语。
See, Mime, too spitz! Look, Snoteman, Sight, Flee, I'm free of me. This episode is brought to you by the Phil Harmonia Orchestra, who are turning 80 this year.
看，密米，太尖了！看，斯诺特曼，看，逃跑，我自由了。本集由爱乐乐团（Philharmonia Orchestra）为您呈献，他们今年迎来了 80 周年华诞。
And to celebrate, they are giving away 80 free tickets for first-timers for every concert in their 2025-26 London season. Now, if you've never booked with the Philharmonia before, you can choose any concert in their London season. They're all at the South Bank Centre. You can get two tickets completely free. There is no catch. Just world-class music live. So the Philharmonia's first concert was in 1945 and ever since then they have been a part of Britain's cultural fabric
为了庆祝，他们在 2025-26 伦敦乐季的每一场音乐会中，为初次观看者免费赠送 80 张门票。现在，如果你从未预订过爱乐乐团的演出，你可以选择他们在伦敦乐季中的任何一场音乐会。它们全部在南岸中心（South Bank Centre）举行。你可以完全免费获得两张门票。没有任何套路。只有世界级的现场音乐。所以爱乐乐团的第一场音乐会是在 1945 年，自那以后，他们就成为了英国文化结构的一部分，
constantly evolving and always ambitious. They have scored more than 150 film soundtracks and video game soundtracks they've collaborated across all kinds of genres, classical icons, jazz, they've even done heavy metal. I mean this is not just orchestral, it is adventurous. So this is your chance to experience one of Britain's great orchestras and some of the world's top soloists in one of the world's great venues to book. Head to philharmonia.com.com.com.U.K. slash free tickets. That is philharmonia.
不断演变，永远雄心勃勃。他们为超过 150 部电影配乐和电子游戏配乐录制过音乐，他们跨越了各种流派进行合作，古典偶像、爵士乐，甚至还做过重金属。我的意思是这不仅仅是管弦乐队，它是充满冒险精神的。所以这是你体验英国伟大管弦乐团之一以及世界顶级独奏家在世界伟大场馆之一演出的机会，赶快预订吧。前往 philharmonia.com.uk/free-tickets。网址是 philharmonia.
dot co.com.com slash free tickets. Come for the music. Stand for the ovation. stuff there from Toby Spence and John Finden and that is from the opera Siegfried the third in a cycle of four operas that are of course known as the ring cycle and Tom you know I'm a massive fan of J.R. Tolkien I do so a sword that was broken being reforged a magic ring all of this does sound very familiar and I guess the question for me and for a lot of people is how much was Tolkien would say the Lord of the Rings how much was he influenced by Wagner because Tolkien always denied it, didn't he? He said, oh, I have nothing to do with Wagner.
点 co.com.com 斜杠 free-tickets。为音乐而来。为喝彩起立。托比·斯宾塞和约翰·芬登带来的精彩演唱，那是选自歌剧《齐格弗里德》，这是一部由四部歌剧组成的系列（即众所周知的《指环》三部曲/四联剧）中的第三部。汤姆，你知道我是 J.R.R. Tolkien（托尔金）的超级粉丝，确实如此——一把断剑被重铸，一枚魔戒，这一切听起来确实非常熟悉。我想我和许多人的疑问是，托尔金——可以说是《指环王》的作者——受瓦格纳的影响有多深？因为托尔金总是矢口否认，不是吗？他说，哦，我跟瓦格纳一点关系也没有。
But it does seem a coincidence, say the least. Well, so to look at the possible relationship of Tolkien and Wagner, I think the best thing is to look at how it is that Wagner comes to write the ring cycle. And the thing is that, like Tolkien, he is obsessed by the mythology and the literature of the ancient North. So early medieval German poems, but also Viking mythology, the sagas of Iceland, all of that. And essentially, in those five years when he's not writing music, and he's in Switzerland following his exile from Saxony, this is what he's doing. He's sitting there immersing himself in Nordic myth.
但至少可以说，这确实太巧合了。好吧，为了探讨托尔金和瓦格纳之间可能的联系，我认为最好的办法是看看瓦格纳是如何创作《指环》四联剧的。事实是，像托尔金一样，他痴迷于古代北方的神话和文学。比如早期中世纪的德国诗歌，还有维京神话、冰岛萨迦，所有这些。本质上，在那五年里，当他没有写音乐、因被驱逐出萨克森而呆在瑞士时，这就是他在做的事。他坐在那里沉浸在北欧神话中。
And it's happening a whole century before Tolkien writes, the Lord of the Rings. And absolutely, Wagner is the first creative artist to recognize the incredible potency of this kind of Norse medieval material. And specifically what he recognizes is the huge potential that it has for someone who wants to create his own mythological world. And so this is what Wagner does.
这发生在托尔金撰写《指环王》整整一个世纪前。毫无疑问，瓦格纳是第一位认识到这种北欧中世纪素材具有惊人潜力的创意艺术家。他具体认识到的是，它对于一个想要创造自己神话世界的人来说具有巨大的潜力。所以这就是瓦格纳所做的。
And first of all, he writes it up as poetry. So again, this is what he's doing in his five years. He's reading, but he's also writing his own kind of mythic account. And in this mythic account, you get Ryan Maidens, you get Valkyries, of course, you get Valhalla, you get Wotan, the king of the gods, you get dragons, you get the magic swords
首先，他把它写成诗歌。所以这也是他在那五年里所做的。他在阅读，但他也写下了他自己的神话叙事。在这部神话叙事中，你会看到莱茵少女，当然还有女武神，你会看到瓦尔哈拉，你会看到众神之王沃坦，你会看到巨龙，你会看到我们刚刚看到被锻造的魔剑。
that we've just seen being forged. And all of this Wagner is putting into poetry, and he's a very, very good poet, and then having done that, he composes the music for it. And then having done that, he wants to put it on, and so he devotes himself to the exhaust, task of trying to raise the money that will enable him to stage the four operas of the ring cycle in the kind of scale and style that he has in his mind's eye.
所有这一切都被瓦格纳写进了诗歌里，他是一位非常非常优秀的诗人。在此之后，他为其谱曲。做完这些后，他想把它搬上舞台，于是他全身心投入到筹集资金的艰巨任务中，这些资金将使他能够按照自己脑海中的规模和风格来上演《指环》四联剧的四部歌剧。
And essentially what Wagner wants for the ring cycle is for it to be, and Dominic, I'm afraid there's only the one word for what he wants it to be, he wants it to be a sacral experience. Right. So I'm on bingo there. But the amazing thing is that he succeeds, doesn't he? Because if we fast forward to 1876, by which time he's actually in his 60s, all his dreams are about to be fulfilled.
基本上，瓦格纳希望《指环》四联剧能够成为——多米尼克，恐怕对于他希望它成为什么，只有一个词——他希望它成为一种圣礼般的体验。没错。我宾果猜中了。但神奇的是他成功了，不是吗？因为如果我们快进到 1876 年，当时他实际上已经 60 多岁了，他所有的梦想都即将实现。
He now has his own theatre in a small town in northern Bavere called Bayreuth. He has effectively single-handedly invented the look, the appearance of Northsmith. So the classic thing, of course, the horned helmet that we associate with the Vikings. and the people who travel to Bayreuth for the premiere, for them it is like a cross between going to a theatre in ancient Greece and a kind of religious pilgrimage, isn't it? Right, and it's hard to get your head around just how massive achievement this is.
他现在在位于德国北部巴伐利亚一个叫拜罗伊特的小镇拥有了自己的剧院。他实际上凭一己之力发明了北欧神话的视觉外观。当然，最经典的例子就是我们与维京人联系在一起的有角头盔。而那些前往拜罗伊特观看首演的人们，对他们来说，这就像是介于去古希腊剧院和某种宗教朝圣之间的体验，不是吗？没错，要理解这是一个多么巨大的成就是很难的。
But you asked about Tolkien before. So imagine that Tolkien, he writes the Lord of the Rings, but they're not content with that. He raises the money for the films of Lord of the Rings. And then having done that, he personally comes up with all the special effects for the films, and he designs the costumes, and of course he composes the music. And this is not something that Tolkien would, in a million years, have thought to do, but Wagner does, and he can do it because he is not only a great musical genius,
但你刚才问到了托尔金。所以想象一下，托尔金写了《指环王》，但他们并不满足于此。他为《指环王》电影筹集资金。在做到这一点后，他亲自想出了电影的所有特效，他设计了服装，当然他还为之谱曲。这绝对不是托尔金在一百万年里会想到去做的事，但瓦格纳做了，而且他能做到，因为他不仅是一位伟大的音乐天才，
but he is also at the absolute cutting edge of culture and technology in the 19th century. So the ring cycle has its, you know, the Valkyries and magic swords and all that kind of thing. But it is also, when it goes on at Bayreuth, the most futuristic musical spectacle ever staged in the 19th century. And it is the kind of ultimate fusion of ancient and modern. And this fusion touches almost every aspect of the production. So there is a dragon in the ring cycle. And Wagner commissions a dragon to be forged in a foundry in Birmingham. And all the bits get sent to Beirut, except for the neck, which by accident goes to Beirut in Lebanon.
而且他也是 19 世纪文化和技术的最前沿人物。所以《指环》四联剧有它的——你知道的，女武神、魔剑诸如此类。但当它在拜罗伊特上演时，它也是 19 世纪有史以来最具未来感的音乐奇观。它是古代与现代的终极融合。这种融合触及了制作的几乎各个方面。因此，《指环》四联剧中有一条龙。瓦格纳委托伯明翰的一家铸造厂铸造了一条龙。所有的部件都被运到了拜罗伊特，除了脖子，它阴差阳错地被运到了黎巴嫩的贝鲁特（注：英文中 Bayreuth 拜罗伊特 和 Beirut 贝鲁特 拼写极易混淆）。
And so this dragon comes on and it has no neck. You have celebrity guests, so you have the Kaiser, not the Kaiser that we do impersonations of on the rest of history, but his dad, Tchaikovsky turns up, a host of other composers, and very much friend of the show, Don Pedro II of Brazil. Oh, lovely to have him back. Great to have him back, isn't it? And he arrives, and he's put up in a hotel, and he's given the ledger, and it asks him for his name,
所以这条龙出场时没有脖子。你有明星嘉宾，比如德皇——不是我们在《历史其余部分》中模仿的那位德皇，而是他的父亲——柴可夫斯基也出现了，还有一大群其他作曲家，以及节目的老朋友，巴西皇帝佩德罗二世。哦，很高兴他回来了。很高兴他能回来，对吧？他抵达后，被安排住进一家酒店，酒店拿给他登记簿，上面要求他填写真实姓名，
so he writes it down, and then it asks him for his occupation, and so he puts down emperor. He's not wrong. Yeah, exactly. And all kinds of things about musical, production begin with Wagner and with Byroyce. So part of the way in which Wagner himself had raised money for it was to go on tour as a conductor, conducting his own work.
于是他写下了自己的名字，然后上面要求他填写职业，于是他写下了：皇帝。他没说错。是的，完全正确。关于音乐制作的各种事情都是从瓦格纳和拜罗伊特开始的。瓦格纳自己筹集资金的部分方式就是作为指挥进行巡演，指挥他自己的作品。
And he becomes the first celebrity conductor. So Ollie's pedigree begins with Wagner. On the stage, the curtains part in the middle rather than being raised. Again, something new with Wagner. And on the first night, the reviews don't just go around Germany, don't just go around Europe. They're cabled across the Atlantic to New York. So that sort of sense of being at the cutting edge, that fusion of ancient and modern, of old myths and the latest technology.
他成了第一位名人指挥家。所以所有的传奇都始于瓦格纳。在舞台上，幕布是从中间拉开的，而不是向上升起。这也是瓦格纳的新发明。而在首演之夜，评论不仅传遍德国，传遍欧洲。它们通过电报跨越大西洋传到了纽约。所以那种处于最前沿的感觉，古代与现代、古老神话与最新技术的融合，
You can see that there is a parallel there with Wagner's most famous subsequent admirer, who is of course Hitler. Because Hitler is obsessed, as Wagner is, with Nordic myths. like Wagner, he has a kind of diabolical genius for using the latest technology, the latest kind of media innovations. And so that takes us back to the question that's hung over this since we started, the question we began with, which is how much do you think the ring cycle,
你可以看到，这与瓦格纳最著名的后世崇拜者——也就是希特勒——之间存在着相似之处。因为希特勒和瓦格纳一样，痴迷于北欧神话；就像瓦格纳一样，他有一种恶魔般的天才，懂得利用最新技术、最新的媒体创新。这就把我们带回了自我们开始以来一直悬而未决的问题，也就是我们一开始提出的问题：你认为《指环》四联剧从一开始就被纳粹主义的毒药所浸染，究竟有多深？
as some critics do, is laced with the poison of Nazism from the very beginning? Well, absolutely, as you say, there are critics who argue that the ring cycle is absolutely putrid with kind of incipient fascism, that it's virulently nationalist, and more specifically that the operas are rife with anti-Semitic stereotypes.
好吧，完全如你所说，有些评论家认为《指环》四联剧绝对充斥着某种初期的法西斯主义，它是恶毒的民族主义，更具体地说，这些歌剧充斥着反犹太主义的刻板印象。
So it is often claimed, for instance, that Mima, who we saw in the scene that was just performed, is intended as an incredibly negative portrait of a Jew, drawing on all the anti-Semitic stereotypes going, so he's dwarish and malevolent and cringing. And this is countered, appointed to the blonde, heroic Siegfried.
因此，人们经常声称，例如，我们在刚刚表演的场景中看到的密米，其本意是对犹太人极其负面的描绘，利用了当时所有的反犹太主义刻板印象，所以他既矮小、恶毒又卑躬屈膝。而这与金发碧眼的英雄齐格弗里德形成了对比。
But for what it's worth, personally, I think that this is completely wrong. I think that had Wagner intended the ring cycle to be anti-Semitic, he would have made it very, very anti-Semitic, and he would have left no one in any doubt about it, because Wagner throughout his life was never a man to hide his opinions, and that, after all, is how we can be certain that he was an anti-Semite because he absolutely trumpeted it. Right, and isn't it interesting that the Nazis themselves, when obviously the Nazis adore Wagner
但无论如何，就我个人而言，我认为这完全是错误的。我认为如果瓦格纳打算让《指环》四联剧具有反犹太主义色彩，他就会把它弄得非常非常反犹太主义，而且他不会让任何人对此产生怀疑，因为瓦格纳一生都不是一个会隐藏自己观点的人，而且，毕竟，这就是为什么我们可以确信他是一个反犹太主义者，因为他毫不掩饰地大肆宣扬这一点。没错，难道不有趣的是，纳粹分子自己——当纳粹显然崇拜瓦格纳
and they love the ring, but actually they don't make a big deal of the ring being anti-Semitic. Not at all, not at all. It's never mentioned. And you would think that, you know, if there was an obvious anti-Semitic subtext of the ring cycle, the one person who would notice it would be Hitler. Right, right.
并且他们热爱《指环》——但实际上他们并没有把《指环》具有反犹太主义作为大肆宣扬的卖点。一点也不，一点也不。从未被提及。你会认为，如果《指环》四联剧存在显而易见的反犹太主义潜台词，那么第一个注意到它的人就会是希特勒。没错，没错。
Yeah. So if it's subliminal, it's very, very subliminal indeed. And that's why I think it's not subliminal, because I just don't think it's there. And it's not just because of the reception of the ring cycle. It's because of the drama that is within the ring cycle. So I said that Wagner is actually a bit of a hippie. The ring cycle is not a celebration of power and domination,
是的。所以如果它是潜意识的，那它也真是极其极其潜意识了。这就是为什么我认为它根本不是潜意识，因为我根本不认为它存在。这不仅是因为《指环》四联集的反响，还因为《指环》四联集内部的戏剧性。所以我说过瓦格纳实际上有点像个嬉皮士。《指环》四联集不是对权力和统治的颂扬，
but the absolute opposite. So the ring does promise. power to those who take it and who want to use it. But Wagner shows the ring enslaving all of those who look to master it. Right, and that's something that obviously would be very familiar to readers of the Lord of the Rings. But this is something that Wagner himself coined, right? Because this is not something that you find in Norse or Germanic myths. There are magic rings, but there are no kind of addictive rings of power.
恰恰相反。因为魔戒确实向那些拿走它并想使用它的人承诺了权力。但瓦格纳展示了魔戒如何奴役了所有试图驾驭它的人。没错，对于《指环王》的读者来说，这显然是非常熟悉的。但这是瓦格纳自己创造的概念，对吧？因为你在北欧或日耳曼神话中找不到这样的东西。那里有魔法戒指，但没有什么令人上瘾的权力魔戒。
Right, and I think that this is because the idea of a ring of power is actually a very, very 19th century one. Because again, it's about this issue of technology. Wagner is writing his operas at a time where it is becoming evident that the power of technology to cause destruction is becoming greater and greater. And of course, in the decades that follow, it will become, you know, it will result in the destruction of the First World War. But Wagner is being prophetic here. And so that's why I think that you asked, you know, is Tolkien? influenced by this idea of the ring as something that is malevolent. I think he is, because I think that, as you say,
对的，我认为这是因为权力之戒的理念其实非常非常具有19世纪的特色。因为同样，这关乎科技的问题。瓦格纳创作他的歌剧时，正值人们日益清晰地看到科技造成毁灭的力量变得越来越大。当然，在随后的几十年里，你知道的，它将导致第一次世界大战的毁灭。但瓦格纳在这里展现了先知般的敏锐。所以这就是为什么我认为你刚才问，你知道的，托尔金是否受到这种将戒指视为某种带有恶意之物的理念的影响。我认为他是受到的，因为我认为，正如你所说，
it's not a notion that is there before Wagner. And actually the interesting thing, again, is that what Wagner pits against the power of the ring, the counterweight to it, is actually something that the Nazis did not rate at all, which is love, the power of love. You see, absolutely hippie? absolute hippie. So what Wagner shows us at the end of the ring cycle, Siegfried is treacherously killed, and he has the ring on his finger at the time. And to Siegfried, the ring is nothing.
这不是瓦格纳之前就存在的概念。事实上，同样有趣的是，瓦格纳用以对抗戒指力量、作为其制衡力量的，其实是纳粹完全看不起的东西，那就是爱，爱的力量。你看，绝对是嬉皮士风格？绝对的嬉皮士。所以瓦格纳在指环套剧的结尾向我们展示的是，齐格弗里德遭到背叛被杀害，他当时手指上戴着戒指。对齐格弗里德来说，戒指什么都不是。
It's just a trinket. He's perfectly able to resist it, because for Siegfried, the great thing is love, and when he dies, it's with the name of his beloved on his lips. And that beloved is Brunhilde, who is a Valkyrie, who has become a mortal, and she, in her grief that her beloved has died, that Siegfried is dead, removes the ring from his finger, and she renounces all of its power in the name of love. And then having done that, she lights Siegfried's pyre, and she climbs onto his horse, and she gallops into the flames of the pyre, and the flames rise and And they consume Valhalla, the halls of the gods, and so the ring cycle ends. And what you are witnessing is Gutter Damarum, the doom of the gods.
它只是一件小饰品。他完全能够抵御它，因为对齐格弗里德而言，最伟大的是爱，当他死去时，他嘴里呼唤着爱人的名字。而那个爱人就是布伦希尔德，她是一个女武神，后来变成了一个凡人，当她得知爱人死去、齐格弗里德死去而陷入悲痛时，她从他手指上取下戒指，并以爱的名义放弃了它的所有力量。然后做完这些后，她点燃了齐格弗里德的火葬柴堆，骑上他的马，策马冲入火堆之中，烈焰升腾，吞噬了瓦尔哈拉，即众神的殿堂，指环套剧就这样结束了。而你所目睹的就是《诸神的黄昏》，众神的劫难。
And the message that the ring cycle ultimately ends up teaching is not a fascist one, but the opposite, that set against the ruin of worlds, ultimately, their end. is only love. I don't know. I don't know. And so, I don't know. All right?
而指环套剧最终传达的信息并非法西斯式的，而是恰恰相反，在世界的毁灭面前，在它们最终的终结面前，唯有爱。我不知道。我不知道。所以，我不知道。好吗？
PON. I mean, and I don't know. And... ...their... ...and... ...a...
PON。我的意思是，我不知道。还有……他们的……还有……一个……
...the... ...the... ...and... You know, I'm going to be able to And... ...and... ...their...
……那个……那个……还有……你知道的，我将会能够……还有……还有……他们的……
...their... ...their... P. ...height. ...and... ...you know. ...and... ...their...
……他们的……他们的……P.……高度。……还有……你知道的。……还有……他们的……
...the... ...and... ...and... ...you... ...and... So, you know, .
……那个……还有……还有……你……还有……所以，你知道的，。
So, I'm going to be able to be. . So, I'm going to be able to be able to be. So, I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm not going to be the I'm going to be able to I'm going to
所以，我将能够成为。 。所以，我将能够成为。所以，我将能够成为。我将要成为。我不会成为我将能够成为我将要
I'm going to I'm I'm going I'm going to be a I'm going to be able to be. ...hean... ...withal...
我将要我将我将要我将要成为一个我将要能够成为。……hean…………withal……
...their... ...and... ...and... ...he... ...their... ...the... ...their... ...and...
……他们的……还有……还有……他……他们的……那个……他们的……还有……
...you... ...the... We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm .
……你……那个……我们将能够成为。我将能够成为。我将成为。我将成为。我……
I'm . . We're going to be able to be. You're going to be able to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be.
我…… 。我们将能够成为。你将能够成为。我将能够成为。我将成为。我将能够成为。
So, I'm going to be able to be. So, I'm going to be able to be. So, I'm going to be able to be. I don't know. I'm going to be able to be. I don't know. I'm going to be able to be. So, I'm going to be able to be.
所以，我将能够成为。所以，我将能够成为。所以，我将能够成为。我不知道。我将能够成为。我不知道。我将能够成为。所以，我将能够成为。
I don't know. I'm going to be. I don't know. And... We're going to be. So, I'm Wow, so that was Siegfried's funeral march from the third act of Gutter Damarung.
我不知道。我将成为。我不知道。还有……我们将要成为。所以，我……哇，刚才那是来自《诸神的黄昏》第三幕的齐格弗里德葬礼进行曲。
And it's a lamentation over Siegfried's funeral march from the third act of Gutter Dameron. And it's a lamentation over Siegfried's death, his Tod, in German, but it's also a celebration of his life and his love, his Lieber. And Tom, those two German words, the pairing of them, Lieber, love, and Tod, death, it's associated with another opera in particular, another Wagner opera, and it's not an opera that's in the ring cycle. Yes, so this is Tristan and Isolder. So let's get into Tristan and Isolder.
这是对齐格弗里德葬礼进行曲的哀悼，出自《诸神的黄昏》第三幕。这是对齐格弗里德之死的哀悼，德语里是Tod，但这也是对他生命和爱情的礼赞，他的Liebe。汤姆，这两个德语词，它们的组合，Liebe，爱，还有Tod，死，它特别让人联想到另一部歌剧，另一部瓦格纳的歌剧，而且这不是一部指环套剧中的歌剧。是的，这就是《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》。那么让我们来聊聊《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》。
Obviously, if you've heard the music, if you've seen it, you'll know that it's 12 hours long. It's a love story, more obviously a love story than the ring cycle. What I'm now going to do is try and tell you what happens in about 30 seconds. So it comes from Arthurian myth. You have Tristan. He's a famous knight. He's the adopted son of King Mark of Cornwall. So King Mark is pledged to marry Isolda, and Isolda is an Irish princess.
显然，如果你听过这段音乐，如果你看过这部歌剧，你就会知道它长达12个小时。这是一个爱情故事，比指环套剧更加明显的爱情故事。我接下来要做的是试着在30秒内为你讲述它的剧情。它源自亚瑟王神话。这里有特里斯坦。他是一位著名的骑士。他是康沃尔国王马克之养子。因此，马克国王许诺要迎娶伊索尔德，而伊索尔德是一位爱尔兰公主。
Now, inevitably, it's an opera, there's a love potion. So, Mark and Isolda, are meant to drink this potion, but again, it's an opera, so Tristan ends up drinking it instead. Tristan and Azolda drink it. Everything goes wrong, inevitably. There are various operatic shenanigans that we don't need to go into. Tristan dies in Isolder's arms. Isolda then consummates their love by dying as well.
现在，不可避免地，既然这是一部歌剧，里面就会有爱情灵药。所以，马克和伊索尔德本应喝下这药水，但同样，这是一部歌剧，所以特里斯坦最后阴差阳错地把它喝了下去。特里斯坦和伊索尔德喝下了它。一切都不可避免地出了错。其中有各种我们不必深入探究的歌剧式滑稽闹剧。特里斯坦死在伊索尔德的怀里。随后伊索尔德也随之死去，以此完成了他们的爱情。
but not before she has sung the single most beautiful and most devastating piece of music in the whole history of opera and that is her Lieberstadt Yeah, it's swooning, it's overpowering Yes folks, it's sacral And above all perhaps it's climactic
但在此之前，她唱出了整个歌剧史上最美妙、最动人心魄的一段音乐，那就是她的“爱之死”。是的，它令人晕眩，它具有排山倒海的力量。是的，各位，它是如此神圣。最重要的是，也许它是如此高潮迭起。
In every sense of the word It is the climax of the opera But Tristan Anizolder is throughout its entire length unbelievably erotic. There are climaxes everywhere. And Dominic, do you want to know what Friedrich Nietzsche? Yes, you do.
在词语的每一个意义上。它是这出歌剧的高潮。但《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》在其整个时长中都不可思议地充满情欲。高潮无处不在。多米尼克，你想知道弗里德里希·尼采是怎么说的吗？是的，你当然想知道。
The great philosopher who admired and despised Wagner in equal measure. Do you want to he said about Tristan? I would love to know. Okay, you've asked for it. So Nietzsche said of Tristan, I have never found a work as dangerously fascinating with as weird and sweet and infinity.
这位对瓦格纳既钦佩又鄙视的伟大哲学家。你想听听他对《特里斯坦》的评价吗？我太想知道了。好吧，这可是你自找的。尼采是这样评价《特里斯坦》的：我从未发现过一部如此具有危险的迷人魅力、兼具诡异与甜蜜的无限性的作品。
Oh, so Nietzsche, who generally bonkers, but in this respect, quite right. Yeah, yeah. This isn't the talking to a horse, Nietzsche. This is the shrewd and analyst of opera, nature. So, we've talked about Wagner as a hater. He's obviously a very good hater. We've talked about his anti-Semitism,
哦，所以尼采，他通常是疯疯癫癫的，但在这一点上，相当正确。对，对。这不是那个对着马说话的尼采。这是那个精明的歌剧分析家尼采。所以，我们讨论了作为仇恨者的瓦格纳。他显然是个非常优秀的仇恨者。我们谈到了他的反犹太主义，
but, Dominic, he also hates the French, which I imagine you're slightly more favourable. to all. He's not all bad. He also, I'm very sad to report, he hates London. He comes here several times and he always thinks the weather's terrible, it's too foggy, people are too obsessed with business, so that's very sad. But Wagner's not just about hating things. He is also very, very good at being in love. And perhaps before we end this show in the most climactic manner possible by hearing the Lieberstadt, perhaps we...
但是，多米尼克，他也讨厌法国人，我想你对法国人可能会稍微更有好感一些。他也不是一无是处。我很痛心地报告，他还讨厌伦敦。他来过这里好几次，总是觉得天气糟糕透顶，雾太大，人们对生意太着迷了，所以这真的很令人遗憾。但瓦格纳不仅擅长讨厌事物坠入爱河。他同样非常非常擅长坠入爱河。也许在我们以最令人高潮迭起的方式、通过聆听“爱之死”来结束这场演出之前，我们……
We could just give a shout out to two people with whom Vargana had very intense affairs. Okay. I think everybody would absolutely love that. Well, and the reason I want to give a shout out for these two in particular is because they're very intimately connected to Tristan and Isolda. And the first of these is a woman called Matilda Wessendonk. And Wagner has a tempestuous affair with her while he's in the process of composing Tristan. and both Wagner and Matilda were married at the time and Matilda was actually married to one of Wagner's most generous benefactors
我们不妨向瓦格纳与之有过极为炽热恋情的两个人致敬。好的。我想每个人都会绝对喜欢这个。嗯，我想特别向这两位致敬的原因是，他们与《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》有着极其密切的联系。其中第一位是一位名叫玛蒂尔德·韦森东克的女性。瓦格纳在创作《特里斯坦》的过程中与她开展了一段暴风雨般的恋情，当时瓦格纳和玛蒂尔德都已各自结婚，而且玛蒂尔德实际上嫁给了瓦格纳最慷慨的赞助人之一
and I think for Wagner the sense of betraying somebody who had always shown him nothing but kindness and financial generosity seems to have slightly titillated it seems to have excited him yeah Wagner was just a bit of a shit wasn't he I think it's fair to say So that's a sort of echo of the plot of Tristan Azola, isn't it? So Wagner is betraying a man who has been very generous to him, just as Tristan is betraying King Mark. Well, you say he's a bit of a shit. He's an artist, and where an artist has to be a shit, an artist has to be a shit.
而且我认为，对瓦格纳来说，背叛一个始终对他在恩情和财务慷慨上毫无保留的人，这种背叛感似乎让他有点兴奋，似乎让他感到刺激。是的，瓦格纳其实就是个渣男，对吧？我觉得这么说挺公正的。所以这有点像《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》剧情的呼应，不是吗？瓦格纳背叛了一个对他非常慷慨的男人，正如特里斯坦背叛马克国王一样。好吧，你说他有点渣。他是个艺术家，如果艺术家必须得渣的话，艺术家就得渣。
Because for Wagner, the experience of writing music is always a very intensely sensory and emotional experience. For instance, he likes to wear beautiful silk clothes, he likes to breathe in the sweetest perfumes. Like you when you're podcasting. Absolutely. And I suspect that to write Tristan, he needed to feel the thrill of an illicit love. And actually, he writes the whole of the second act while he's on holiday in Venice with Matilda.
因为对瓦格纳来说，创作音乐的体验始终是一种非常强烈的感官和情感体验。例如，他喜欢穿漂亮的丝绸衣服，喜欢呼吸最甜美的香水。就像你做播客的时候一样。绝对是的。我猜为了写出《特里斯坦》，他需要感受到一种禁忌之爱的颤栗。事实上，他在威尼斯和玛蒂尔德度假时写完了第二幕的全部内容。
And they've both, you know, Wagner's left his wife behind, Matilda's left her husband, and you can see that this would get the critical. Creative juices flowing, I suppose. Well, yes. Well, I mean, the result is, listen, the result is one of the great masterpieces of 19th century culture. But the problem for Wagner, I guess,
他们两个人都，你知道的，瓦格纳把妻子抛在脑后，玛蒂尔德离开了丈夫，你可以看出这能让批判性的创意灵感如泉涌般喷薄而出，我想。嗯，是的。好吧，我的意思是，结果是，听着，结果是19世纪文化的伟大杰作之一。但对于瓦格纳来说，问题在于，我猜，
is he's written Tristan and Azolda, but putting it on is a very different matter because basically he doesn't have any money. Right, yes. And this is certainly the case for the first five years after he's completed Tristan. But then, brilliantly for Wagner,
他写出了《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》，但把它搬上舞台则是另一码事，因为基本上他根本没有钱。没错，是的。在《特里斯坦》完成后的最初五年里，情况确实如此。但随后，对瓦格纳来说极其幸运的是，
massive stroke of luck. In 1864, he meets the second of the great loves of his life that I wanted to talk about. And this is not a woman but a man, and he's called Ludwig. He's only 18 years old, and he has just recently been crowned as king of Bavaria. He's the second Ludwig to be king of Bavaria, so Ludwig the second. And he, more than any of the superfans that we talked about in the first half,
迎来了巨大的好运。1864年，他遇到了我想要谈论的、他生命中的第二大挚爱。这不是一个女人，而是一个男人，他叫路德维希。他年仅18岁，刚刚被加冕为巴伐利亚国王。他是第二位名为路德维希的巴伐利亚国王，所以是路德维希二世。而且他，比我们在前半部分谈到的任何超级粉丝都要疯狂，
I mean, he's the ultimate superfan, possibly in the entire course of the history of music. Because it is Ludwig who funds Wagner's theatre, a Bayreuth, and it is Ludwig in 1865 who coughs up the cash that enables Wagner to put on the first production of Tristan. And I think Wagner was not gay, unlike Tchaikovsky, but there is an almost erotic quality to his relationship with Ludwig. So ministers of kings throughout history have always worried about their royal master chucking cash at a royal mistress. And the ministers of Ludwig II are kind of very similarly anxious about the amount of money that Ludwig is shoveling towards Wagner. And there is a kind of quality of two lovers about their relationship
我的意思是，他是终极超级粉丝，可能在整个音乐史的长河中都是如此。因为正是路德维希资助了瓦格纳在拜罗伊特的剧院，也正是路德维希在1865年掏出了资金，才让瓦格纳得以举办《特里斯坦》的首次制作演出。我认为瓦格纳并不是同性恋，不像柴可夫斯基，但他与路德维希的关系中有一种近乎情欲的特质。因此，历史上各国的国王大臣们总是担心他们的皇家主子把钱大把大把地砸在皇家情妇身上。而路德维希二世的大臣们对路德维希向瓦格纳倾注巨额资金也抱有非常相似的焦虑。他们的关系中有一种情侣般的特质，
locked in a kind of very intense passion. They're always quarreling, making art, pledging eternal love, and then the cycle goes round again and again and again. And you talk about Ludwig as a superfan. I mean, Ludwig is the first of many, isn't he? You know, composers had inspired devotion before, of course, Mozart, Beethoven, whoever, but in Wagner's old age, and then especially after his death, he inspires an adoration of a kind that no composer has ever inspired before. So he really is a composer with fans, with superfans, and I guess that's partly because he's an extraordinary self-promoter, but also because, as we've heard, there is and just an unbelievable power
深陷于一种极其强烈的激情之中。他们总是吵架、创作艺术、誓言永恒的爱，然后这个循环周而复始、不断上演。你把路德维希称为超级粉丝。我的意思是，路德维希是众多粉丝中的第一位，不是吗？你知道的，作曲家以前也曾激发过狂热崇拜，当然，莫扎特、贝多芬、无论哪位，但在瓦格纳晚年，尤其是他死后，他所激起的崇拜之情是历史上任何一位作曲家都从未引发过的。所以他确实是一位拥有粉丝、拥有超级粉丝的作曲家，我想这部分是因为他是一个了不起的自我宣传者，但也是因为，正如我们所听到的，他的作品中蕴含着
and intensity to his work. Yeah, and so I think that Europe gets gripped by what you could legitimately call Wagner mania and Wagner mania among Wagnerians is still very much a going concern and certainly if Wagner is hated and there are lots of people who have hated him and who do hate him, then so also is he passionately,
难以置信的力量和强度。是的，因此我认为欧洲被你可以名正言顺地称之为“瓦格纳狂热”的浪潮所席卷，瓦格纳主义者中的这种狂热至今仍然大行其道，而且当然，如果瓦格纳遭人痛恨，且有很多人曾经痛恨他、现在也依然痛恨他，那么同样地，他也受到了狂热的、
passionately adored. And I can't think of any composer actually who has before or since who has been the focus of such extremes of emotion and when you listen to the Lieberstadt as we're about to do from the end of Tristan and Isolda, I think you can see why. Right.
狂热的崇拜。我想不出有哪位作曲家，无论在此之前还是之后，能成为如此极端情感的焦点，而当你聆听“爱之死”时——正如我们即将从《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》的结尾所听到的一样——我想你就会明白其中的原因。好了。
So ladies and gentlemen, that brings us towards the closer tonight show and that is what we are going to end with. But first we have a host of thank yous. So first of all, thank yous to our brilliant goalhanger team. Executive producer Tony Paster, who's with us tonight, a great man. We have backstage Hannah, Alia, Izzy and Julian,
所以女士们先生们，这把我们带向了今晚演出的尾声，这也是我们将要以之收尾的节目。但首先我们要感谢许多人。所以首先，要感谢我们出色的挂球（Goalhanger）团队。执行制片人托尼·帕斯特，今晚也和我们在一起，一个伟大的人。我们在后台还有汉娜、阿莉亚、伊兹和朱利安，
who have been shoveling sushi down Tom Holland's throat and fueling Arthur Sandbrook with pizza. We have our dear, dear friends in business class, our producers, Theo Young Smith and Tabby, Siret, the other two members of the rest is history, quartet. And of course, we have our brilliant conductor, Oliver Zephman, one of the most talented young conductors out there, without whom we would not be here tonight. And our thanks also to the Philharmonia Orchestra. And if there are any people here who are here to,
他们一直把寿司塞进汤姆·霍兰德的嘴里，并给阿瑟·桑德布鲁克提供披萨作为能量补给。我们在商务舱里有亲爱的、亲爱的朋友们，我们的制作人西奥·扬-史密斯和塔比·赛雷特，“历史就是这样”四重奏的另外两名成员。当然，还有我们才华横溢的指挥奥利弗·泽夫曼，他是当今极具才华的年轻指挥家之一，今晚如果没有他，我们就不会站在这里。我们也要感谢爱乐乐团。如果在座有任何人，
tonight who have not so I just wanted to say if there's anybody here who I just wanted to say if there's anybody here who this is their first experience of listening to a live orchestra I mean the Philharmonia orchestra powerfully demonstrate why it's so much better to come and listen to a live orchestra than to hear music on Spotify. Absolutely. Not least when you have the brilliant soloist that we've had this evening. Marta Fontaineau-Simmons, Christine Burris, Mari Wynne Williams, Ella Di Young, Rebecca Aronwee Jones, Katie Stevenson, Lea-Zoo, Toby Spence and John Fendon.
今晚还没……所以我想说，如果这里有任何人，我只想说，如果这里有任何人的这是他们第一次体验聆听现场交响乐团，我的意思是，爱乐乐团有力地证明了，来现场聆听交响乐团演出，比在Spotify上听音乐要好得多。绝对如此。尤其是当我们拥有今晚这样出色的独唱家时。玛尔塔·方特诺-西蒙斯、克里斯蒂娜·伯里斯、玛丽·温·威廉姆斯、埃拉·迪·扬、丽贝卡·阿龙维·琼斯、凯蒂·史蒂文森、廖簌、托比·斯彭斯和约翰·芬登。
What brilliant, brilliant performers there are doing. And finally, our thanks to Ingle of Brimberg, who now over the corpse of Tristan will sing of love and death. So thank you and goodbye. Good night. Thank you. Thank you. Oh... ...howan...
多么杰出、多么出色的表演者们啊。最后，我们要感谢英格·布林伯格，他现在将在特里斯坦的遗体旁歌唱爱与死。所以谢谢大家，再见。晚安。谢谢。谢谢。哦……howan……
...that... ...and... ...I... ...and... ...and... ...and... Oh. Oh.
……那个……还有……我……还有……还有……还有……哦。哦。
Mild and lice, VIII and lice, Who in Dachelt, Who, the eyes, that one day wendent, see it's your friend, see it's freud, see it's gist,
never light, never lighten who look at, oh, oh, man, aster man, who I'm,
who I'm, see it not, see it not, When you're sweet, love I'm ashamed, come and hear, and hear, the fass of the smearth, In the Menden
Only in Mourn Mourin's light Sucan Sucan Wend Wend Father, fainty!
Friender! Friender! Seat! See! See, see, and see, is not yet, and see, is not. No, I am I only the least, I'm only in this light,
This light, is no longer by the end up herein'er, and in the lighten, and in the lighten's, night, never fordent, as him shed, whome, shedet me, wringet,
out, shinget, hollet, Olethull, women, no longer. I'm there
are men are they are so they're they're
, Are you all in the light of the dame? How I see she fulch, I'd rushes, I'd watch, for me I'd watcher, for you'd watch No, the shorthen, and to thawain,
Suss in the light of the fashen holmen, in the wilding shone, in ternsame, in ternment-shell, He said, Oh, God Sonne and
all in arms and I think of course. Oh, you must. You know, It is the year. Yeah.
I'm... I'm going to be. Yeah. ...this... ...you know... ...and... ...the... ...withal...
So thank you so much, thank you so much for listening everybody. Now, we will be back next week. And I'm sorry to say there will be no musical accompaniment because it will be business as usual. And on Monday, we'll be resuming our normal service with a mighty series based on medieval history. And it is the life and career, the extraordinary achievements of one of the very worst people in history. That person is, of course, Joan of Arc. So a massive thank you once again to Oliver Zephman, to the Philharmonia Orchestra, to the Royal Albert Hall, and to our brilliant soloist Leszou, Ingler Brimberg, Toby Spence and John Finden. Thank you very much.
非常感谢大家，非常感谢大家的聆听。接下来，我们下周还会回来。我很遗憾地通知大家，将不会有任何音乐伴奏，因为我们将恢复正常的工作状态。周一我们将恢复常规服务，带来一个以中世纪历史为基础的宏大系列。它讲述的是历史上最糟糕的人物之一的生平、职业生涯以及非凡成就。那个人当然就是圣女贞德。因此，再次向奥利弗·泽夫曼、爱乐乐团、皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅以及我们杰出的独唱演员廖簌、英格·布林伯格、托比·斯彭斯和约翰·芬登表示衷心的感谢。非常感谢大家。
And happy new year, everybody. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
祝大家新年快乐。拜拜。拜拜。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。